House Speaker Paul Ryan says Congress
needs to focus next year on spending we
spoke earlier this morning and asked him
about cutting entitlement benefits which
account for 64 percent of the federal
budget I know you're a budget walk and
I've looked at it too and if you look at
the pie of where most government
spending is it is entitlement spending
you had talked about reform for a long
time senator bob Corker said yesterday
that he had a conversation with you
about that so will Congress take up
entitlement spending next year yes we
will and Bob and I actually see a lot of
these things very similarly we have to
address entitlements otherwise we can't
really get our handle on our future debt
there's two things you need to do to get
the debt under control so that our kids
and our grandkids get a debt-free nation
number one grow the economy this tax cut
bill will help do that number two reform
entitlement programs we're it's it's
unfortunate that our health care bill
which passed the house last May didn't
get through the Senate but we need to
revisit that issue because that's key
entitlement reform and then back to the
welfare issue we right now are trapping
people in poverty and it's basically
trapping people on welfare programs
which which prevents them from getting
to hit their potential and getting in
the workforce the problem we're gonna
have with a faster growing economy it's
a good problem is we're gonna need more
people working and so we need to work on
our welfare programs so that we can ease
the pathway and reduce the barrier from
getting people from welfare to work
that's very insignificant entitlement
reform as well and so that's something
we're gonna tackle next year Democrats
oppose cutting entitlement programs
Vermont senator Bernie Sanders told us
earlier this month that Republicans want
to make cuts that will hurt the most
vulnerable Americans